whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners up the DEA for
thwarting a University scientists
decade-long fight to grow and study
marijuana and the DEA who's real ban on
fake pot just kicked in a substance
called spice that some young people are
using to get high but there can be only
one nanny of the month and this time
it's DEA administrator Michele Leonhart
for raiding medical marijuana
dispensaries in California and Montana
you know on second thought let's go with
her boss what I'm not going to be doing
is using Justice Department resources to
try to circumvent state laws on this
issue oops kind of looks like that's
what you did more than a dozen times in
March alone so what is your position mr.
president because you keep saying you'll
stop the raids but then you sick armed
agents on dispensaries who say science
will guard you then ignore the studies
that say pot has medical benefits if
it's even more evidence you want then
stop messing with scientists who want to
conduct more research and now it's on to
fake pot the Drug Enforcement Agency has
banned the five most common chemicals
used to make spice so now manufacturers
will simply replace the illegal
chemicals with the new ones that might
be more dangerous than the band ones and
almost certainly won't be as safe as
real marijuana which the DEA zone
administrative law judge once called one
of the safest therapeutically active
substances known to man did you inhale
that was the point
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minded your own business
the war on drugs has been